Thanks for having us say no problem. I'll
do it. Well, I'm going to be doing good.
Doing good.
Good.
So you both are twin
brothers from Australia. Yup.
Curious to know how you both that
started in the film making industry. Uh,
we say
jump the back fence into
the film industry. Uh,
we were in design for for quite a while.
We were in motion graphics artists, uh,
dealt with a lot of post production,
visual effects,
that kind of thing in the early two
thousands and around the same time as each
other around maybe six
months from each other.
We both jumped into directing live
action at production companies for
advertising commercials,
that kind of thing.
Started to do commercials, music videos,
you know, a lot of live action stuff.
And in about 2007,
uh,
we moved to the states together to New
York knowing that La might end up being
further down the line. And so did a decade
in New York doing mainly advertising,
good spots for Google, but
you know, a bunch of things.
And it wasn't until about 2014 that we
just felt a little restricted with the
shorter form a narrative stuff. 30
seconds, 60 seconds, sometimes 15 seconds.
Yeah. And felt like we wanted to
stretch our legs a little bit.
And that's where bag man, this short film
that Ken is based on inspired by, uh,
came about.
Great. And what kind of work did you
guys do for Google now that you're here?
A number
different things.
There was some stuff for the phone
originally and then that got canceled.
There's like,
there was a bunch of different
things with a few different agencies.
You guys got money so yeah.
You guys
stop and scrap stuff. I'm sure you
were aware of that a little bit.
Um,
and as brothers who created number of
short films and just like your first spots
together, um, how do you guys merge
your ideas and influences together?
I feel like brothers get on
each others tails your look.
Yeah,
it does for us as well.
I mean a lot of people say I could
never direct with my brother or sister.
And Yeah,
some people like that where the type of
twins that have grown up liking the same
stuff, having the same taste.
Yeah. Uh, generally we've,
you were in high school together,
college together.
We're in a brief stint in
the army reserves together.
We've done a whole range of stuff. So it
just makes sense that we have the same
taste. Yeah, no, it works. It works well.
I think going into high
stress environments, uh,
this isn't necessarily one of them,
it's a bit casual. Uh, but you know,
you're in a board room
with studio executives or
whatever and you're pitching a
movie,
you want your bro there to kind of
backyard and it's nice to have someone to
take over and you have a second to
think for a minute. And yeah, no,
it works really well.
It's great. And when you guys were
looking at two potential careers,
how did you guys come up with filmmaking?
Did you guys have a moment in your earlier
years that you thought filmmaking is
the career
for me? Yeah. We've always been
obsessed with movies. I'm sure you know,
millions of people are.
But I guess back in the 90s,
whenever we could get our hands on
a camera, uh, we would, you know,
from high school, all that type of stuff.
And we started making our own thing.
You usually we were emulating stuff,
so it was like watching trailers and
they're making our own backyard version of
trailers and all that kind of
junk. Uh, early on as well.
We had a fascination with putting visuals
to music and that led quite easily
into the music videos.
Totally.
And just like creating emotions
with very simple stories. Um,
a lot of the time with no dialogue,
which bag man became the
lead character in the short,
which you can check out online. Um, it
doesn't say a word in the entire film.
Right.
And so carrying over that very simple
aesthetic of minimalism and quietness into
a studio feature film was
interesting because you know,
your lead character needs to say to him
and stuff at times. Great.
And speaking of which,
tell us a little more about kin, uh, the
trailer we just saw. Yeah. Well look,
it's a,
it's the last movie of the summer.
So we're transitioning into movies that
are maybe a little, hopefully smarter,
uh, awards fair, things like that. Um,
I think this movie has a taste of both.
It's,
it's got some big Saifai concepts,
stuff in it as you can
see from the trailer. Uh,
but it's not your traditional Scifi.
It's also got a much more of an influence
with character and a story about
brothers.
We figured out pretty quickly when we
wanted to turn bag man into a longer form
project that, uh, we really
needed to dive deeper.
And so we didn't want to be handcuffed
by the things that were in the short
necessarily.
So we were,
we felt like we were free to change
certain things and adapt and things.
And so we figured out it's about family
and then specifically about a very
unconventional brother unit.
And what does that look like?
Like are you only brothers
if, if, if it's blood, uh,
is it circumstance and the things
that you go through trauma,
like what brings brothers together? So
that's really what the movie's about. Um,
essentially this kid finds a giant crazy
alien space rifle and that does not
belong in this movie.
But that's the challenge to try to make
it all feel as grounded and realistic as
possible.
The other half of that sort of genre tone
with the Scifi is a much more sort of
indie spirited, you know,
character drama. Uh,
there is elements of crime stuff in there.
There's a coming of age road trip.
It's really multiple things.
And what turned us on is just things
that are harder to define. You know,
coming from advertising is very easy to
get put in a box and we early on became
the visual effects guys and you've got,
you know,
transforming cars and houses and rooms
and in their fun stuff and they generally
have big budgets.
Um,
but at the of the day we have
influences from, you know,
more modern,
gritty crime dramas like out
of out of the furnace or,
or place beyond the pines or mud or
you know, these more sort of quiet,
a sophisticated sort of filmmaking.
And it's the partnership of those two
with Scifi that makes this really unique.
That's great.
I know we saw James Franco in that film
talk a sub and more about the actor and
actress selection. How you guys
decided who goes in this film.
Well you basically do a top five list
for every role and there was months of
discussion from outside of just who's
right for one thing you definitely don't
want to do is write the
screenplay thinking of an actor,
horrible idea because you'll
always disappoint yourself.
But with this top five lists you
go through and you're like, okay,
who are we going to go out to?
And the casting process can be really
frustrating because you've got to go one
at a time.
We're not auditioning when I bring it
all these giant act as like Dennis Quaid
into a room and getting him to do
his lines. It's not the way it works.
So you go out one by one to these people
and you wait for them to say they're
available or they're interested
or whatever it may be.
And we were really lucky
to team up with 21 laps.
The guys who made stranger things,
uh,
which wasn't made when
we joined up with them.
We just knew of this Netflix
show though doing on the side.
And I said they do really good stuff and
they can easily get on a phone and say,
James, uh, these, these
are really good guys.
They've got a great script and now that
they haven't done a movie before, try it.
Trust me, watch this short film
and get back to us. So, uh,
we were really lucky. Zooey was out
number one and we actually got it,
which is kind of incredible.
Uh,
she has this sense of cool that
you can't fake a, and she, yeah,
she's Kinda perfect for the role.
And then James came up, uh, through
Shawn Levy, one of the producers,
and we'd always liked the more sort of
spring breakers side of, of his career.
And He loves playing with
darker characters that
have a very sort of in your
face.
Charisma makes you uncomfortable.
It makes you not know whether you would
need to laugh or sort of pull back in
your seat.
And he plays a character.
I A mallet wearing a Cosby sweater wearing
a gun runner in this and he's one of
those characters that kind of is pretty
terrifying but also has some very
comedic moments. It's, yeah. Yeah.
Uh, the other, the two brothers,
I mean it's about them. Uh,
the older guys, Jack
Reynor, he's an Irish actor,
has actually quite a dense
Irish accent in, in real life.
He was in a bunch of indie our cinema
movies like, um, glass land with, uh,
Toni Collette,
what Richard did by Lenny Abramson.
He was even in a giant
transformers movie, which, um,
I'm pretty sure he doesn't
want to be in again. Uh,
and so maybe for his house
though. Yeah, probably.
We wanted someone that you might have
seen before and he was in Sing Street,
one of our favorite, he's
a great character in sing
street. Um, thanks Rick Fan.
Yup. Right here in the red. Uh, so we,
we put someone in that lead role that
you might know, but you're not like,
you really know.
I think Jake Gyllenhaal and that role
might what might've worked as well because
you want to learn who these two brothers
are without kind of being clouded by
something.
And then the lead kid,
we auditioned heavily for this and it
was a very difficult role to find someone
who was NCLR and emotionally mature and
someone who could stand up in a room
full of adults and feel like they belong
and isn't trying to like sing and dance
for you the entire time.
And this is his first
movie. Like we, yeah,
we had nothing to go off
other than an audition tape,
a self tape from home on a phone.
And uh,
we just really were impressed with the
fact that he didn't come out trying to
impress us.
He had the confidence to kind of pull
back and be very subtle with it all.
And yeah, he, he's, he's brilliant.
It's his movie. That's awesome.
And as you guys are working
with these actors and actresses,
how are you guys working
with each other on set?
Well, I think rule number one is we want
to try to not contradict each other.
That's, that's, that's
not rule number one. Yeah.
I mean the last thing you want is to be
sitting at the monitor and you have an
idea and you run up and you tell them
something and then Josh has an idea and
run up and says the exact
opposite nightmare material. Um,
but yeah, we, we 50, 50 everything, we
have the same tastes like Josh said.
So we trust each other. There's mutual
respect there and, okay. Yeah. Yeah.
That's awesome.
And as we're coming up
kind of on time here, um,
what's next for you guys? What are you
guys thinking about with your next move?
We have a really killer science-based
TV show that we're looking at right now.
We're developing with the writer of
arrival. Um, and it's going to be killer.
You guys are actually
gonna really like it. Uh,
hopefully that's something that comes
out and a premium channel at some point.
We're pitching it out
at the end of the year,
but then just a couple of
movies and different things. We,
we certainly don't want to, like I said
before, get put, sort of put in a box.
We like telling interesting stories
and unique stories. Uh, this,
we're just lucky that this first one
is very personal to us and came from
something that we did as a short
film. So yeah, we're really,
I'm interested just as much to
find out what's next. Um, you,
the movie hasn't come out yet,
so hopefully it changes things up.
It's hard to know.
That's great.
And we want to open it up to
Q and a from the audience.
So if anyone has a question, feel
free to walk up to the mic. Yeah,
we'll tell you what's up, man. What's
your name? Nelson. What's up Nelson? Um,
first of all, I'm really excited
because I love Carrie coon. She's,
she's great man.
I'm also more gray,
so I think they did a great question.
Yeah,
I know they've done a soundtrack for
this French show that I really love.
Was it working in sort of the,
the process of working with a band
like Mogwai to sort of say, look,
we got Mogwai stories for days
there. They're really, really cool.
It's one of our favorite bands.
Um,
we knew at the very beginning that we
wanted to go with a band on this and not a
traditional composer just to have a
different life for the music so that it
could come out in an album and have
its own fan base. Let's be honest.
It was a selfish endeavor.
Yeah. Hell yeah. You want to
hold a vinyl in your hand?
Definitely. And so we did a playlist
that went for about 13 hours.
That was from bag men and
then we transferred over to
the movie and we just kept
adding to it and we gave it
to the rider to listen to.
So it was just kind of set the tone.
Yup.
And there was a lot of Mogwai
in it and we realized one day,
why don't we just ask Mogwai.
So we did.
And they get offered really big
stuff all the time. He said,
and they turn it down like big Hollywood
movies and they'd never done a movie
before.
Like you said,
they only done a French TV show and a
bunch of docs and where they are on the
phone and they say, yeah,
we really emotionally,
emotionally connected to you as screenplay
and we'd love to do your first movie.
And we were just like, oh. And we
went on mute and then it was like,
they're cool guys and we've
got to go to Glasgow and,
and sit in with this in
the studio with them.
And in a sense like help produce
one of our favorite McGuire.
I'm going to switch like when
does that ever happen? Yeah.
Now their locker leasing not only the
soundtrack that the score soundtrack,
but they're going to, well they have, uh,
taken cues and stretch them out into
full length studio song. So it's,
it's a Mogwai I'll cold call again.
It's ridiculous.
And you should pick it up cause
it's a really solid album.
Comes out of the day a, the movie drop.
So August 31st I'm excited to hear that.
Um, and then one last question is, uh, so
you were mentioning how this has a more,
you know,
family centric and I really love that
about these newer Scifi movies like
arrivals or midnight special if
you've seen it. Yeah, absolutely.
I can loop or even any thoughts of great
references continuing like exploring
that SciFinder you have this TV show
that's hopefully going to come out or are
you into other genres that you have?
It definitely man.
Like John was saying before,
we don't like being boxed as directors.
It's kind of really limiting.
So yeah,
we like all kinds of film and that there's
so many different references in this
from like 80 to mud to all the way
upstream district nine to like,
it's moonlight meets
district nine in a weird way.
There's so many different things going
on and that's just purely because we like
a lot of different movies and, and,
and why can't they all be in white?
Why can't they all sit in the one film
where you telling me you go and see it?
And maybe they don't,
but we think they do. Uh,
so when it comes to the stuff that we want
to do in the future, yeah, I think so.
[inaudible] is a part of it,
but we're also interested
in, in other things. I mean,
the movie that Damien Chazelle is looking
at right now about, um, the mood killer,
man, we'd love to do something
like that. So who knows? 6,000. No,
appreciate it.
Hi. Hey, how are you? Hi. Origin
Harris. Found Australian Australia.
Okay. Maybe a little bit more.
Maybe more than us. He goes,
I've lived here 17 years. So
who knows? Try Sound. Um, no.
First I just want to ask you
and nothing super technical,
but I'm really very proud to see
Australians on stage ever. Thank you.
They kick ass work. I it, that's the first
thing. And Americans, everybody else.
But we're not talking about them right
now. Between you and I. Well, no,
but I'm just very curious about,
you know,
the life that you had in Australia and
obviously you were involved in this kind
of stuff or at least burgeoning into
this stuff when you're in Australia. Um,
what kind of different perspective do
you think it does give you coming from
Australia and you know,
there's a lot of Australians in la and
sure there is. It was part of the reason
we moved to New York to be honest. Um,
look,
we have always felt like we are a little
bit of an outsider coming into the
industry and coming through
advertising as well.
We have a different perspective
on certain things, um,
certainly aspects of the film
quite timely as well. Um,
and so yeah, we have it. We have a
unique perspective. I think that's
always helped. What do you think? Um,
in Australia we worked mostly
music, video and advertising. Um,
so we didn't really have a chance to dive
into the Australian film industry per
se. I think they're doing some
super respectful staff. Um,
I think it's small and I think it's, um,
there's a ceiling on it in Hawaii. So,
so if you want to tell a really big story,
you've kind of got to bring everything
else down to make it work for the money.
And that's disappointing or
limiting. It's limiting. Um, so I,
I do think a lot of people get up and
move and obviously London and La are two
massive options.
I think there's a shit ton of
talent coming out of Australia and,
and that's why we have a lot of actors
and maybe Americans don't even know half
of them are Australian. But like
there's a lot that are doing really,
really good stuff. Yeah, I dunno.
I don't think we could have
made this movie in Australia,
which is disappointing in some ways.
But then the way we've approached it
by putting the two tones together,
I think is very Australian.
So I dunno,
I'm actually really interested in how
it goes down there and what the response
would be because we're,
we're trying to do some promotion with
over there and hopefully people see it.
Oh Man.
Do it pimp away.
Good luck. Thank you. Appreciate
that. Paris. Thank you. Paris.
Okay.
Hello. Hey, how are good? How
are you? Where's your name?
Susan. Hey, nice to meet you.
Um, from this far away, um,
my question is about the diversity of
the cast and how intentional that may or
may not have been and if we can expect
to see more of that in your work.
For sure. I mean, again,
sort of stepping into America and
seeing a lot of the conversation that's
happening,
uh,
in one way is super encouraging because
things are changing in another way.
It's kind of disappointing that
we're even talking about this.
And so this is just us playing our part.
I mean,
it's more interesting to us to have a
story about a young African American lead
that is finding a MacGuffin
from a Scifi movie.
And we just don't see that.
I mean, said that awhile ago,
white kids had been fine in alien
spice space rifles for far too long.
Let's mix it up a little bit. So, yeah,
so,
so it's two things.
The first is it's just more interesting
as a filmmaker because you want to dive
into something that feels different and
unique. Uh, and on the other side, um,
you know, we made a short, we lived in
New York and we said it in Harlem and,
and we will definitely going to keep
that vibe when we moved over to make the
movie. Uh, it's really,
really refreshing and
okay,
really delightful to see the reactions
from young black teens when they see this
movie to be honest and
representation is super important.
And seeing themselves up on the screen
and seeing how this character's arc, uh,
evolves is awesome and we've
had some great responses.
Thank you Beth. Appreciate it.
One more question here. Awesome.
Last one. I guess I'm Chris,
what's up Chris? I'm curious about,
so I spent a couple of years
of my twenties in attempting
to be a screenwriter.
Uh, and I'm curious that when you guys
were trying to make the leap into first
feature film and one of the struggles
that I had as a Scifi writer was how do
you, how do you determine like, you
know, the story you want to, right?
How big do you make it based on,
you know,
that budget's going to be hard to come by.
Like you want to tell you the right way,
but then the more cool scenes you pack in,
the more dollars start to grow.
He's a really cool question.
Um,
I feel like coming from visual
effects really helped us with that.
We know what things cost and
so we've restrained ourselves.
That's probably the right word,
restricted ourselves when we have told
stories for the last 15 years because we
know where it gets a little dodgy
because you're like, I don't,
I can't afford this and we don't want to
be doing the scene that we can't afford
in a really bad way.
So this movie is a really good example
of that where we do some big things in
this and,
but
all right,
nothing is ridiculous. Nothing gets to
the point where you're like, well, wow,
they spent billions of dollars and an
[inaudible] is not one green screen in
this movie. It's all very practical.
Props were made, environments
we created, sets were built.
We're dealing with a young 14 year old
actor that's never been in a movie.
We had to make it as realistic as we
could for him. So that was one reason,
but another is just, we've always been
very responsible directors in a weird way.
I don't know if that's
a thing to brag about.
It could be a batch coming
from advertising you, you know,
like what the budget is and you
know what you can afford, you know,
what things cost. So, you know,
we just started putting
ourselves out there to fail.
Well,
we had a lot of conversations specifically
on this movie about how far do we go?
And,
and I think this is the anti giant movie
in a way because you're getting all of
that stuff still, but we're
making you care about it. Um,
we're starting slow and we're,
and we're,
and we're introducing to
these characters and the,
and it takes a little bit before
the gun comes out and gets fired.
And we're like,
obviously that's part of tightening
the noose intention and all that stuff.
Expectation.
But then we're also,
we're never going to that place where
you'll start rolling your eyes and you're
like, all right, that
just got really silly.
And I think that's just done on purpose.
We want it to feel real world.
And the Buzzword is grounded Psi Phi man.
So like keep that shit grounded.
Thanks guys.
Yeah.
Well thank you guys for
coming by our office.
Thanks to Evan has visited
Jonathan Jazz's a Google page.
Go to Google them a twin.work.
Um, they also Facebook,
Twitter and Instagram and go check
out Ken. Next week we're around. Yeah.
Uh, maybe drops the August 31st in Imax.
Can't believe we've got an imax release.
Yeah. Just, just lastly though,
the Imax and D Tsx One of the best
surround sound audio in the world.
It's crazy that you put out a trailer
and people like the trailer and then
suddenly we've got Imac saying,
we'd love to put you guys on for a week.
And so now we have imax and in dts
x knocked on the door and said,
this looks really cool.
We'd love to give you a full surround,
like the best sound in the world.
So it's one of those amazing things and
you'd make something cool and people
come knocking.
So
take their word for it. Go check it out.
Thank you. Thank you. I appreciate it.